the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 Q&A video I know I haven't made one of
these videos and quite some times so
today I want to answer some of your
questions there are a few questions I
want to get to you right away because
these are the ones that I often see in
the comments section of nearly every
video I release as you can see by the
title of the video the first topic I
want to discuss has to do with Ned
Stark's final words right before he was
executed near the end of the first
season so without further ado let's
begin the first question was left by
Harsha did Ned Stark save Valar
morghulis when he died and if he did say
that is it safe to assume that he must
be one of the faceless men just a wild
question nothing else thank you for the
question for those of you who might not
remember that scene let's take a quick
look at the clip that way we can refresh
everyone's memory make sure you pay very
close attention and Ned Stark because he
does whisper something right before he
is executed
like I said earlier I can't even begin
to tell you how many times I have seen
people ask this question so I figured it
was time to finally address it now
thanks to the actor Sean Bean who
portrayed Ned Stark back in the first
season I believe we can finally put that
question to rest some of you might not
like the answer because it is a bit
underwhelming however I do believe it to
be true during an interview with The
Huffington Post the actor revealed what
he whispered right before his death and
he also gave the reason behind why he
chose to do this now I do want to
apologize if any are you are watching
the video on your cell phone because
some of this may be a little bit hard to
read but I will read it to you
nonetheless the last time we saw Sean
Bean played Ned Stark
ser Ilyn Payne was chopping off his head
with ice Ned Stark's own Valyrian steel
sword it was a rough moment and one that
established Game of Thrones as a show
willing to do the unexpected it's also
an iconic moment fans discussed to this
day for example have you ever noticed
that Ned mutters something right before
the end
fans have long tried to guess Ned's
final words is he saying Valar morghulis
or perhaps he's saying I kept my promise
referring to his pledge to keep Jon
Snow's parentage a secret one theory
even states that Ned was whispering to
bran the three-eyed raven when speaking
to The Huffington Post beans own
explanation is simpler Ned was saying a
prayer this is what the actor had to say
it appears that way doesn't it I
couldn't be too specific because I don't
know if religion like that was around in
those days whatever they were I just
thought what would I do if this were
really gonna happen you would probably
pray you probably would murmur some
words and you'd keep it quiet you'd keep
it to yourself it's quite subtle and
that many people wouldn't pick it up it
was an interesting thing to do for me at
that point there's not much else you can
really do you've got your head on a
block that's about the only thing you
can do is murmur so as you can see
according to the actor who portrayed Ned
Stark his final words before his
execution had no actual significance to
the story's plot
this was not something that the writers
or producers told him to do this was an
actor's choice just to add a little
something extra to the scene now I know
there are a lot of fans who did wage
that Ned Stark was still alive me
included but unfortunately this is not
the case in my opinion Ned Stark is not
a faceless man what he whispered way
before his death has nothing to do at
the end game Ned Stark can continue to
live on inside of our hearts but I
highly doubt that we will ever see him
back in the show unless it's and one of
brands flashbacks now let's move on to
the next question this one comes from
Robert Shaye what would be your biggest
disappointment in the final season
someone surviving someone dying a
horrible ending what would it take to
sour everything for you this is a very
good question Robert because this is
something that I think about quite often
actually I would be lying to you if I
said I wasn't nervous about the final
season I'm not so much worried about
which characters they decide to kill off
the show I'm already well aware that any
character can die at any given time one
of my main concerns is how they tell the
ending to the story of the night King
and the White Walkers as we all know
they have been one of the biggest
mysteries and Game of Thrones in A Song
of Ice and Fire this is something that I
myself have put a lot of thought into
the threat of the White Walkers were one
of the very first things introduced into
the story we were led to believe that
they are the biggest threat in the realm
even though they weren't at the
forefront of the story I always knew
there would come a time at the end of
the story where the White Walkers would
become the main focal point
well now that day has finally come now
that the wall is down and the White
Walkers are moving south and no Westeros
the writers can no longer ignore this
part of the story and they have only
given themselves a handful of episodes
to tell the rest of the White Walkers
story there are only six episodes left
yet we still don't know that much about
the way Walkers we don't know why the
White Walkers came back now and we don't
know what the White Walkers actually
want nor do we even know who the night
king actually is these are some of the
biggest mysteries remaining in the story
and depending on how the writers decide
to answer some of these questions could
ruin how we view the White Walkers of
the night King in my opinion we do need
some more answers about the night King
and the White Walkers back story if they
end the show by leaving us complete
in the dark I would be very disappointed
about that however I am fairly
optimistic now I don't think they will
give us all of the answers but I do
think they will give us some of the big
ones now let's move on to another
question this next question actually
received the most amount of likes so I
am assuming that some of you really want
to know my answer for this one this is
another question that I see left in the
comment section of almost every single
video that I make this one is from
exquisite elephant and now that the show
is ending what do you think you will do
with your channel you could still talk
about the books but there isn't a ton of
things to talk about were you thinking
about diversifying your channel this is
a really good question and I did intend
on making a separate video where I would
go into all the details about the future
plans for the channel to be honest with
you this is something that I think about
every single day one thing that I do
want to make very clear is just because
Game of Thrones is coming to an end I
don't want anyone to think that my
channel is coming to an end as well I
have every intention of continuing to
make videos for as long as possible like
I have told some of you before the only
way I will ever stop making videos as if
my channel would get terminated for some
reason or if I would end up in the
hospital or something like that
now hopefully neither of those things
happen as long as I have access to a
computer in the internet I want to keep
making videos because it is something
that I really do enjoy making now I do
know that with Game of Thrones coming to
an end I'm sure I probably will lose a
lot of subscribers because that is the
only reason why most of you are here but
hopefully some of you enjoy my videos
enough to see where I take things next
as I'm sure most of you already know HBO
is creating another show that is based
in the isang of Ice and Fire universe
they are currently in production with
the new show that is set during the Age
of Heroes which is right around the time
the White Walkers were created and how
stark was founded this was also at the
same time in which Winterfell in the
wall was built as well as the Nights
Watch getting founded so I think this
new prequel show does have a lot of
potential
like I said before I will absolutely
continue to make videos about the new
show and I'm hoping that most of you
stick around for that because of they
are filming that first episode very soon
I'm thinking that we are gonna see the
new show sooner rather
than later HBO will want to ride that
wave Game of Thrones has created so it
would be in their best interest to
release the new show shortly after Game
of Thrones does end like I said I will
make videos about all of that and I will
also continue to make videos about the
books as I'm sure most of you know
george RR martin still has two more
books to release in order to complete
the original story i do imagine that the
next book the winds of winter will come
out shortly after the final season in
Game of Thrones is released when it
comes to the books I have barely even
scratched the surface in my videos that
is because I wanted to save all those
theories for when after the show comes
to an end I still believe the books and
the show will have two different endings
to a certain extent the reason for this
is because the books are able to explore
so many different characters as opposed
to the show the books will give us so
much more information about the Citadel
the faceless men bloodraven children of
the forest and the White Walkers along
with many other things that the show had
to abandon because of time constraints
just think about how many different
storylines this show wasn't able to
include from the books all of those
storylines will get some sort of ending
in the books which I do plan on making
Theory videos about shortly after the
show does end so trust me when I say
this I still have tons of videos to make
after Game of Thrones is over and I also
want to make a bunch of videos that have
nothing to do a game of Thrones or A
Song of Ice and Fire
I have thought about this for quite some
time and I will talk about it some more
during season 8 when I know I have
everyone's attention I think that would
be the best time for me to tell everyone
about my plans for the channel after the
show ends because once this show is back
on that's when everyone will be watching
my videos for the most part so if you do
want to see more videos from this
channel just make sure you stick around
because I don't plan on going anywhere
anytime soon this next question comes
from India mange facts and it says when
do you think the trailer for season 8 is
going to draw my answer would be very
very soon my friend I would say that the
first official trailer will drop within
a few weeks actually we might even
actually get another teaser for King's
Landing first because they did already
drop a teaser for Dragonstone in
Winterfell so we might get one for
King's Landing since we haven't seen
anything for Cersei Lannister yet either
way whether they drop another teaser or
not I still believe the first official
trailer welcome
in a few weeks I actually thought that
they would release it this month in
January since they have released a bunch
of trailers in January for their
previous seasons if you go back and look
at the dates of all the other trailers
you will notice that all of them were
released shortly after the new year so
if they do not release the trailer this
month then there is a very good chance
that they will release it during the
Superbowl which is in a few weeks the
Superbowl was on February the 3rd and
it's arguably the most viewed event of
the year
so that would be a great time to release
the trailer since it is the final season
for the biggest show in television
history I imagine they will want to do
something special for that trailer if
you remember last year they released a
trailer for Westworld during the
Superbowl so maybe they do the same
thing for Game of Thrones as well I
think that would be a safe bet let me
know down below when do you think they
will release a trailer also let me know
what type of videos you would like to
see me make after Game of Thrones is
over I would love to get some feedback
from all of you anyways I want to thank
everyone that's submitted a question for
the video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone who
continues to support the channel on
patreon that really means a lot to me
thank you all very much I hope everyone
has a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
you